[Music]
what was your relationship with your
writers like i started out as a comedy
writer and always knew that i'd like to
perform but that's where i spent the
first uh seven eight years in the
business was writing and i was always i
live among the writers i tackle them i
beat them up they beat me up that's the
kind of relationship we have what kind
of relationship did you have with your
writers well i didn't tackle them but uh
i
like on wednesdays i remember the
writers would get together for lunch and
then they would show old clips from uh
comedies you know from sid caesar and
milton berle and jackie all the classics
so this one wednesday at lunch i went in
to talk to the head writer and i hadn't
looked you know and i'm kind of
whispering to him
and i'm hearing moaning
and i looked up
and it was a porn film
the writers were watching pornography
well they knew i was coming in
i love how nothing's changed also in
comedy writing
and i looked at that and i went oh
that's just terrible
and ernie said to me carol he is doing
the best he can
i want to say i i i hated when i was
younger having
red hair when i was a kid i but a
consolation for me was that two
extremely funny women uh from television
lucille ball and carol burnett had red
hair and uh i thought of myself as a
young woman uh
in comedy in comedy yeah uh but i that
was always inspired me but that was that
was an accident for you i remember uh
one time when i would do q and a with
the audience you know at the the start
of the show love that part this cute
little guy i think it might have been
about 12 and he had the shock of red
hair and everything and he raised his
hand i called on him and he said
when you were in school did they tease
you about your red hair yeah
i said no
i didn't have red hair
so
no
well it's brown yeah it's probably white
yeah